booklet care podcast man special guests
in here representing Dallas representing
bird Vision Arlington Texas Arlington
let's you know whatever Dallas Arlington
Tomatoes Tomatoes my guy Dino
what's up well first of all
what's Arlington and Dallas what's the
how far is that because it was like 15
depending on what part of Dallas which
city is more racist
uh our city for some of my races
Arlington yeah sounds more racist yeah
yeah it's Cowboy stadium over there now
so I think that's where it's at yeah you
know I slept with a girl uh she worked
at uh
it was in Plano Texas and she worked at
what's the place that's like Hooters but
it's like
um uh uh Twin Peaks
I snatched a [__] out of a twin peaks
in Plano Texas yeah WrestleMania weekend
2015. nah Texas is fun great City I [__]
with it I like Frisco in Plano the area
back there yeah crazy as houses and you
could bring your own bottles to the
strip club something I've never even
known was a thing until I went there to
six and it's all new
you can see [__] and everything
which is a good and bad thing they got a
big glow thing let me just be changing
colors in there oh they put butt plugs
in their ass what the strippers do what
that sounds like a risky
damn it's going down shout out to the
butt plugs hey well listen man what you
got going on with the shout out we're
about to have you freestyle with like
you know music out music coming give us
the rundown uh I just released my fire
well my second single with epic and very
Vision through a label uh with DJ Khaled
right youngin congrats uh yeah no so now
I'm gonna drop again in April I'm
working on that right now something for
the ladies so I'm gonna try to you know
trim it down when you get Khaled on the
record is it just him talking [__] like
do you know
and I just focus on my music you know
what I'm saying and bad [__] [__] with
the music you know what I'm saying and
they [__] birds so that [__]
disconnected in a way so it's like when
autumn Energy's together that [__] is
this is magnificent it's Magnificent the
Dream Team shout out to my guy bird
shout out to dombo man let's get right
to it baby let's go
[Music]
gotta show her how I feel take my family
to see different Water Breeze in Brazil
any color bag I buy longest bae you keep
it real need that old school love ain't
got it worse they hold me have some dark
days so I appreciate my brighter ones go
to Brown grave I gotta take on all the
Fallen ones don't have any plans to have
all type of fun fans pushing for my mama
I'm stacking all type of stuck in
traffic and no rush running late to get
this place I won't let no gravity [__]
pay my life away kept it solid when they
ain't solo ride into
[Music]
memories they'll still be Vivid glorify
the real ones not the money other
[__] [__] they ain't really
stepping they just always had some dark
days so I appreciate my brighter ones go
to burn grave I gotta check on all my
Fallen ones six siblings so I'm having
plans to have all type of sons being
pushing for my mama I'm stacking all
type of fun stuck in traffic in a rush
running late to get this type I won't
let no gavity [__] take my life away
kept it solid when they ain't solo ride
into that thing I be focused when they
came who gonna help me if I think it
won't call out right or left free super
day every Dave being getting paid my
life get in super bay rapping on this
mate I need a super race I'm talking
about them other guys
play the next one hey hey hey
free super man that's what I do this
[__] for dang the real is back in rap
hey why play your major like my pops but
I wish that I could change kicking [__]
wish I could stop but I'm addicted to
the game any day where I can pop you
know the price won't stay the same it'd
be hard to make it out she either
rapping now you slang I'm a curb in the
home run here I'm a real [__] hard to
keep a bond with you if you turn me on
imma make the song feature got your ass
alone trying to have a son with you
double what they spend then do it time
ten you know when we spinning got a
slide team lately I've been faded while
I'm driving pulling up on ape [__] when
I slide in I'm a lover boy I'm paying
for the petty bad chocolate [__] look
like you shine for belly pops did it big
so I gotta do it heavy back though a
[__] [__] them over for that fetty baby
for me good cause [__] dying in the
street better stand on how you feel they
put in its teeth buy a crib it's really
ready hey buy a crib I need to get it it
ain't fine where you sleep we've been
swerving and everybody's a bird
I wish that I could change kicking [__]
wish I could stop but I'm addicted to
the game any day boy I can pop you know
the price won't stay the same it'd be
hard to make it out she either wrap it
now you're slain imma curb in the home
run hitter I'm a real [__] hard to keep
a bond with you if you turn me on imma
make the song feature got your ass alone
trying to have a song with double what
they spending do it time teen care you
know when we spending got a slide team
lately I've been faded while I'm driving
catch them on the 10 shoot his ass in
his hand hey on the fire I've been L.A
too long but I'm from the Texas and this
[__] a new song hey baby love me promise
I won't move on [__] with a [__]
taking out your new Throne hey come to
the crib we got better balls up in the
hills
[Music]
yeah you rap [__] really be a music
don't underestimate it that's when
you're gonna get confused [__] with a
[__] [__] probably Adam blew a fuse
uh FoxFi put them on the news we ain't
entering that cause my mama know I got
little screws I've been running to this
paper till my feet hurt hey I've been in
L.A so long I upgraded my net worth uh
carrying that whole game and got my back
hurt
I know real pain
my God you killed that [__]
it was cool that was hard bro you went
like [__] eight minutes straight it
felt like golly not a lot of people
could do that
yo how can we how can we uh find you
online let everybody know where they can
find you at bro everything is at AAP
Dino look what I'm saying hey AP Dino go
run it up new single with Khalid I said
another one's coming yeah yeah I'm
dropping some uh April then I'm gonna
try to aim for the tape party into the
summer is the tape done
I'm probably like 600 songs in 600 easy
600 songs I like
600 you like 600 and I like okay I'm I'm
40 this year well listen man you gotta
[__] uh put that [__] out I do but
you know what I'm saying I work so hard
and then it's like I don't know but
don't overthink it just drop it I can't
overthink I'd be overthinking that [__]
yeah Dino AAP Dino go follow him man
shout out to my guy bird shout out to
Don Bo you already know man the bootleg
kept podcast boom hey I know you just
watched a new freestyle guess what we're
dropping them every week sometimes more
than once a week Jesus we've been
dropping a lot lately uh shout out to
LRG don't forget go to
l-r-g.com use the promo code bootleg
save 30 off at a checkout you get this
look at this jacket look at that lining
it's LRG baby 30 off this bad boy go to
l-r-g.com promo code bootleg and save 30
off at checkout and check out another
freestyle next week